it was a star-studded send-off for the
greatest voice of our time Aretha
Franklin right behind us in the greater
grace temple they streamed her funeral
to a worldwide audience but we were the
only show backstage with the superstar
performers who came to pay tribute to
Aretha we have all the moments that you
didn't see as we said goodbye to the
Queen of Soul
[Music]
[Music]
Jennifer Hudson honored the Queen of
Soul with Amazing Grace Faith Hill the
first soloist a Teresa's homegoing set
the gospel tone with a soul infused
version of what a friend we have in
Jesus afterwards she was overcome with
emotion ariana grande who arrived with
fiance Pete Davidson paid tribute with
an Aretha classic
[Music]
Pete was waiting backstage we've had
mean to be here and perform the dance
[Music]
everything I read the Franklin is she is
music
she is music
and I spoke to an emotional Chaka Khan
before her performance today of the
gospel song going up yonder I loved her
very much
we loved each other I'm honored to be
able to be here and give her a beautiful
send-off the producer behind today's
ceremony Curtis Farrell told me the
biggest names in music were happy to
honor Aretha everyone was just excited
and said absolutely because everybody
knew that this is a history-making
moment we truly have lost a history
major there were so many powerful
speakers today had a chance to talk to
Motown legend Smokey Robinson just
moments before he paid tribute to his
friend of nearly 70 years Aretha was my
longest friend who was still alive so
now you know she's gone home so I'm here
to make sure that she had a great home
going and to celebrate her life really
gonna miss you it's really gonna be dear
friend with
from childhood friends in Detroit to
Motown stars in ultimately lifelong
confidants inside smokey recalled the
first time he heard a wreath is
god-given voice eight years old you sing
it and that was my first meeting and my
first sight of you and you're gonna be
one of the featured voices in the choir
of angels because you know you'd have to
be she gave it all that everything that
God gave her as far as a gift is
concerned she used it and she used it
also to make a difference in the world
Gladys Knight joined stars like Whoopi
Goldberg Tyler Perry Cicely Tyson and
Jennifer Lewis of course there will be
tears but we have her music that song
pink was played at the end of President
Clinton's tribute there were 27 speakers
who paid their respects to the Queen of
Soul let me give you a few more numbers
from the service there were 18 musical
tributes and this was supposed to be a
private funeral for 4,000 people but at
the last moments the family decided to
let in 1,000 members of the public
earlier six pallbearers assured the
Queen of Soul down her last ever red
carpet into the temple inside seven
video cameras and three still
photographers captured these candid
moments Aretha was again dressed in
those Christian Louboutins for wardrobe
changes in four days fitting for a queen
because Aretha was a very classy woman
she wouldn't have stepping I love the
red
and this was a heartwarming sight
as a tribute to her hit freeway of love
more than 100 pink Cadillacs were
brought in from all over the country and
parked just outside the chapel usually
if it moves me than other people like in
a repo told et she knew her 1985 single
would be a hit the video was a lot of
fun it was my first and we did it at
Doug's body shop here in Detroit I
thought it was very nice and today it
was fitting to see this Cadillac a white
1942 door LaSalle again transporter
Rita's body in 1984 it carried her
father the Reverend CL Franklin to his
funeral and in 2005 Rosa Parks
Franklin sang at that service in the
same chapel and told us about honoring
her fellow civil rights icon
and animation this really was one of
those days you'll never forget and it
was the perfect send-off for royalty now
Aretha will be buried in the same
cemetery as her father and Rosa Parks
you know we were so lucky to be blessed
with time in Detroit with Aretha and a
little bit later a special treat Aretha
in her father's Church the place where
she found her voice with a final goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]